the jogan experience when do you think
the first news arrived that of this
catastrophy July
4th July 4th 1876 the 100 100th
anniversary of the approval of the
Declaration of Independence our 100th
our 100th
birthday news arrives of of this
crushing of Custer you know the nation
the military was not going to let that
stand you know so this was part of the
reasons there was this this
extraordinary effort you know to to
destroy these
people so they very quickly broke up
into these constituent bands uh and
tried to get away as best they could and
less than a year they were they were
defeated and you talk about what
happened after that in your other book
on the NZ purse the last Indian War yeah
right yeah that was the next year uh
1877 uh the npers were this
Extraordinary People in the Pacific
Northwest uh they were from Idaho from
Eastern
Oregon they too composed of these
different bands gathered together in
this uh this one common identity the
nimu which means the real
people uh and they were completely at
peace with the whites in fact uh Lewis
and Clark had been the first uh the
first Americans the first white people
that they had ever seen leou and Clark
came over a little low pass uh downed
there they were
starving uh and the ne uh the nesp took
them in um saved them uh gave them
helped them get some U uh horses uh and
canoes to keep on their way and on the
way back uh Lewis and Clark stay with
them more more than a month and they
formed in the eyes of the N Pur they
formed this alliance with the Americans
and they swore from this time on we're
friends we're allies uh you help us when
we fight we'll help you when you fight
and that was in 18 uh
six uh they kept that promise from 186
until
1877 wow as they were their lamb was
being overrun uh as these
uh uh appalling treaties were being
forced upon them um they kept their word
uh and then finally in 18 uh 1877 the
government said okay that's enough you
got to come into this
reservation and the ones who were living
off of it uh had to then within one
monthin a month they had
to pack up everything they had
to leave their Homeland that they had
known for Generations uh they had to
cross the Snake River at its highest
point somehow get their families you
know women children kids old folks um
across this River to gather to go into
this
reservation end of a way of life
um even though the treaty that required
them to do that was a was a was a was a
a fraud uh and on the Eve literally the
day before they were to go onto the
reservation to be forced on the
reservation these young men sort of
snapped and these young men took off and
killed a bunch of fight folks you know
that they had grudges against um that
then triggered this War uh triggered
this larger outbreak against whites that
then of course brought the Army in uh
and the Army tried to to put this down
but
as I researched that book uh the
question that keep kept coming back to
me was
why why did they do
that because at the time of the War uh
they were completely at peace with the
Americans around them uh they had
adapted
beautifully they were prosperous
Cattlemen they were raising cattle you
know uh they had silver tea sets for
Pete sake they were they were more they
were more prosperous than the whes who
were who were living in the in the area
they threatened no one they were living
on lands and the whites didn't want uh
why then why force them in what's the
reason and the only reason I can think
of was um the little
born this year before this
humiliating
defeat at the hands of the uh of the
lotas and the cheyen uh with that the
government said uh okay that's it
everybody even our best
friends have to give up and they have to
come in into reservations where we will
we will control them yeah they'll
control them and their Force
Christianity on them as well yeah yeah
have you seen uh Taylor Sheridan's uh
series uh 1923 it's a a pre a prequel to
Yellowstone have you ever watched any of
those shows no really good show but one
one of the things that 1920 three
documents it stars Harrison Ford and so
it's very interesting but it it
documents these women that are forced
from their tribe to go into these
schools MH where their uh Christianity
is forced upon them they're beaten and
treated horrifically it's it's very hard
to watch because you know that that is
what happened of course yeah that's the
boarding schools yeah that goes way back
before 1923 by 23 it's sort of it's sort
of winding down um but yeah all sorts of
course scandalous uh
news recently in the past year or two
about the kinds of uh treatment that
came out of those done those schools
here in Canada the same sort of thing is
being revealed in in in Canada about the
abuses under those under those schools
yeah it's not just Christianity that's
being forced on they are
uh required uh to speak only English
they're punished if they speak their own
languages yeah uh they for they give up
their their appearance cut their hair uh
dress in a certain way uh now there's a
wonderful irony in that
show uh I said a moment ago uh most
people most in the public think of uh
you know the Indian as if there's one
group of people right the the
Indian native people of course didn't
think at all like that uh they
identified with tribal groups they
identified with the band within the
tribal group groups
uh often at odds with each other you
know they've been fighting each other
like everybody fights everybody else in
history so their identity was you know
when you say uh what are you they would
say well I'm a cheyen I'm a kamachi you
know I'm a clink you know I'm a whatever
I belong to this guy's band um so the
idea of and of the Indian was uh
completely foreign to them uh m
until boarding
schools and all of a sudden in boarding
schools all the kids all the young
people are taken required to go to these
schools all of these different
groups they're all living
together they're all forced to surrender
much of their own individual cultures
those dozens of different cultures that
they were U um they' come from um and
suddenly it begins to Dawn on them uh
they're now all speaking the same
language right they're
all you know we've got much more in
common that we have differences among us
so there's a
way in which um you know the supposed
purpose of a boarding school was to
destroy
indianness yeah the famous uh phrase
coming from a uh Colonel Pratt who was
the one who founded Carlile was uh uh
kill the Indian to save the
man destroy Indian identity in order to
allow these people to survive in the
modern world wow but what the r schools
did was in fact create the Indian they
didn't kill the Indian the Indian didn't
exist before that it created this sense
of common
identity the sense of okay we may be
kamachi we may be shy be Lakota may be
or whatever but we're all we all have
this
common problem that we're facing these
common difficulties so we need to think
in terms of the Indian to bond to to uh
you know to uh to bond together just
like on a smaller scale when these bands
decide to uh to join and unite in order
to fight the military now on this much
larger Continental scale Indians from
all over native peoples from all over uh
the nation now begin to see the they are
related related in their circumstances
not B blon so the Indian was created not
killed in the boarding schools that's
fascinating when they initially tried to
move the natives to
reservations how did they were they
doing it because where the natives were
there was valuable resources were they
doing it because geographically they
could control them better in these
regions like what was the motivation
initially it was all of that yeah
certainly they were
uh especially when they're in particular
places that uh are very rich in
resources great examples of course were
mining rushes um these people who are
again hunter gatherers uh living in
someplace this remote Mountain area in
California or Arizona or wherever uh
suddenly you know they're overrun by
these people coming in overrun because
they are uh they are living on some of
the richest places uh in the nation uh
so you got to get rid of them right uh
uh but there's also the reason this is a
way to control them and to in the eyes
of the government to transform them
right put them on these reservations and
you can turn them into the kind of
people that you want them to be yeah
make them
American and that's what so was both of
those things both of those things
together which is historic like when we
look back at it now it's like one of the
most horrific aspects of it that we just
TR to eliminate them and just integrate
them into our culture right that was
always the uh the formal government goal
it wasn't simply give them a place to
live the way they live it was no no
virtually no one was saying that je even
the people who were were called part of
a formal term Friends of the Indians
they organ organization called the
friends of the Indians and they were uh
honestly in their own Hearts they
thought that they were doing what was
necessary for the best for these
people but this is uh they said the only
way we can do that only way that these
people can be saved is to transform them
into people like us to make them into
our uh to integrate them into our our
culture uh and that uh that depended on
really basic through three things uh it
was uh it was uh they had to become
Farmers because you know from the
beginning in this country you know
that's sort of the ideal life that's how
you that's how you begin your your
integration into the American economy
Farm you know the Jeffersonian Vision
you know of the ideal farmer um they got
to be
Christian we have to have this common uh
common religion uh
and education we've got to take their
young people and we've got to put them
in schools where they will be not only
learn the basics of the three Rs and so
forth but they'll be culturally educated
yeah they will be culturally transformed
so these boarding schools U Were Meant
to transform these people into Americans
what they you so yeah uh so we you often
hear the term G side thrown around uh
and there are times in American history
when that was absolutely true when there
was an effort to Simply eradicate Indian
peoples uh but the whole reservation
system was not meant for
that sometimes it turned out that way
but the purpose of it was this
control and transformation that's what
was supposed to happen and then when
that happened once that was done then
they the reservations would be done away
with every body would uh uh live in
harmony you wow it had didn't happen of
course but of course it had to be so
confusing to them what the resources
were that the white man wanted too
because they're like why do you want
gold like you can't eat it you can't use
it as a weapon yeah so strange it is in
a lot of ways it is uh you know gold as
you said it's it's virtually useless
it's it's very soft
right so you can't make it into a what a
strange thing to be the most
valuable of all Commodities it's really
shiny how bizarre that so many parts of
the world had agreed upon that that's
right it's just cross culturally across
hundreds of years the the uh Egyptians
you know yeah Egyptians call Gold the
Breath of God you the Aztec uh consider
it a god scat this was the excrement of
the Gods you know that came
so strange so strange yeah now it's not
true I think that uh once there's some
really interesting Works going be going
on right now by um historian name
Benjamin
badley uh who is studying in California
uh in in the Gold Rush there were
Indians who said
oh they're going to give me a bunch of
stuff for this stuff of course and so
they went they went to work and there
were there were hundreds of Indians who
were in The Gold Fields before the uh
honors came really
yeah